hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's edition of
what I eat in a day youtuber reviews I'm
gonna be taking a look at Jen a from
sweet potato soul now jenna is a vegan
chef blogger cookbook author and
youtuber who is known for her vegan
recipes and plant-based cooking tips
she's also a new mom to a super adorable
one and a half year old girl and has
documented her vegan pregnancy and what
she's feeding her vegan baby now Before
we jump into my review today a quick
reminder to of course subscribe this
video and ring the bell so that you
never miss out on any videos I also want
to serve my general disclaimer that the
information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always seek out the
help of a registered dietitian or
medical professional for your unique
case also please be kind in the comments
both here and on Jenny's Channel we need
to keep this a supportive space for
learning okay let's meet Jenny we
already had breakfast this morning of
course and so you've been awake since
5:00 still cut oats today we get the
instant pot either have that like I did
today or I have to have porridge while
I'm eating I often feed her solids
today she had a super tuna with spinach
and then awesome butternut squash and
every morning I have my very necessary
and delicious matcha opinel black tank I
sweeten with okay so I love Janae's
style for making oatmeal in the instant
pot and let this be a PSA for all of the
busy folks out there if you haven't
purchased an instant pot you got to get
on that stat it's great also for making
baby friendly foods as well because it
makes everything super tender and soft
really really fast
as for jinae's breakfast you all know I
love oats in the morning so this is
definitely a great start and steel-cut
oats are slightly higher in protein and
fiber than rolled oats with a slightly
lower glycemic index as well so that is
great
I also heard her say that she's
breastfeeding at the time of this
video and oats are commonly thought of
as a galactic GOG aka a food that
increases breast milk supply now
research wise there is no great evidence
that oats actually make a big difference
but they are rich in iron which tends to
be lower postpartum and they feel really
like soothing and relaxing to eat in my
experience so that also may help with
milk supply now I didn't see her make
this so I don't know exactly what is in
Jenny's oats but it looks like maybe
some raisins maybe some plant-based milk
in there as well she also has a matcha
oat milk latte which sounds super
delicious I love the addition of maple
syrup but of course if she wanted to
boost up the protein which nursing does
increase needs for she could opt for
some soy milk over oat milk which has
about 8 grams of protein versus 3 grams
per cup respectively we could also add a
little more satiating fat in there with
some almond butter flax hemp or chia
seeds but overall this looks like a
really hearty satisfying meal as for her
babe
sweet potato spinach and squash all
sound like a great starter meal for
solids and I get that not all moms are
comfortable with baby led weaning and
prefer to spoon feed baby but at 10
months old which janae says her daughter
is in this video babe is definitely
ready for some solid finger foods as
well so hopefully we'll see that Nick's
into the rotation let's take a look at
snack I have a little pair it seems like
every time I leave the house I leave the
house super hungry because it just takes
that long to get over the house oh my
gosh those are two of my absolute
favorite fruits of all time and fruit is
definitely a great quick grab-and-go
snack that you can enjoy while you're on
a walk or as you're prepping lunch as
Jenny is doing and you guys know that I
always recommend pairing your fruit with
a source of fat or protein but also as a
busy mom I totally understand that
sometimes you're just like on the go and
you need something really quick and
handheld and easy and fruit is
ultimately a nutrient-dense easy choice
I personally love Asian pears because
they provide anywhere between a 4/10
9 grams of fiber depending on the size
but of course if we threw in some nuts
or seeds or something like that made a
little trail mix this would make this an
even more satiating snack let's see what
Genna prepares for lunch that meal kit
Neal looks totally amazing and I can
totally appreciate a good meal delivery
service as a busy breastfeeding mom
preneur and this particular meal looks
amazing and well-balanced
we've got protein and carbs from the
chickpea and millet we've got healthy
fats from the avocado and some lovely
produce from the beets greens and citrus
I also love how this recipe features
millet seeds as the primary green which
provides a lot of nutrients that can be
harder to get on a plant-based diet like
calcium and iron plus it's a source of
protein a quick tip of course for
cooking millet is to soak it overnight
prior to cooking as this will help to
enhance the nutritional absorption and
digestibility let's see what else are
you eating honey bunny
you had your mouth and now it easy
and flash love a good ginger tea and it
is considered a safe herb for breast
milk production so that's great as her
baby jays meal looks like she's getting
in some pincer grasp practice here which
is amazing and so important at her age
and since of course we want to focus on
iron rich foods in the first six months
of solids I'm happy to see that you know
sweet potatoes and peas and squash are
actually all solid plant-based sources
so yummy mama let's take a look at snack
I'm hungry again
I've just finished feeding the baby so
I'm gonna have some tortilla chips and
hummus oh girl I remember those nursing
days I mean the hunger is sometimes just
like insatiable on average you burn
about 20 calories per ounce of breast
milk produced and I have no idea what
Jen a produces but when my son was 10
months old I was pumping around 45
ounces a day which if you do the math is
an extra 900 extra calories required
your girl could eat so on average most
nursing people need an additional 400 to
600 calories and this snack ticks all
the boxes in my books it's convenient
it's fast it's delicious and it's filled
with protein fiber and fat and by the
way babies love hummus too so that would
be great for baby J as well let's move
on to dinner I'm thinking tofu teriyaki
[Music]
okay so since I saw this I was totally
inspired to make tofu teriyaki at home
because it looks so damn good now we've
got some protein from the tofu tons of
fiber from the bell peppers and the
leafy greens as well some complex carbs
from the black rice now I don't know
anything about the tofu that she used
but I usually recommend especially if
you are following a vegan diet to ensure
that you're buying a tofu that is
calcium set or has calcium sulfate
listed on the label as this will help
you get a little bit extra calcium into
the diet I also think it's great that
Gen a is using black rice which research
actually is shown to have the highest
antioxidant activity compared to other
rice varieties black rice also contains
a plant-based pigment called anthocyanin
which research suggests may have
anti-inflammatory antioxidant and
anti-cancer properties let's move on to
day 2
[Music]
love a good tofu scramble I mean it's a
great egg swap and is packed with
protein calcium and iron and this meal
is fantastic in general I mean we've got
carbs from the potato veggies from the
kale and bell peppers protein from the
tofu and vegan sausage and some fat for
cooking now let's see what she has to
say about her supplements okay so I love
that Jenna is taking a supplement and I
also like ritual products too and this
multi does have Omega 3 b12 d3 and iron
which are often the nutrients of concern
in a plant-based diet so that looks
great let's take a look at lunch
[Music]
okay so in typical busy breastfeeding
mama fashion Jenna is eating her lunch
in two parts
she's got leftovers first and then after
she breastfeeds and puts a baby to bed
she takes a time to prep herself a kale
salad and this meal as a whole is just
incredible I mean she's got carbs from
the squash rice and sweet potato protein
the chickpeas and black beans family
avocado and of course lots of fiber rich
veg with the massage kale and massaging
your greens isn't just for fun getting a
little oil or lemon juice on there and
go into town definitely makes it easier
for those tough fibers to break down for
digestion plus it adds a ton of flavor
kale is actually one of my favorite
greens for everyone but especially for
vegans because two cups of raw kale
provides around 20% of your daily
calcium eats and 11 percent of your
daily iron recommendation which is great
during pregnancy and for rebuilding
stores postpartum now let's see what's
for snack
so oranges see mm-hmm
gorgeous looking oranges and I think
three is a great snack especially if
you're breastfeeding and your fluid
needs are extra high since oranges for
example are about 88% water but of
course if she wants to boost up the
satiety factor especially if she is
feeling extra hungry from nursing
pairing it with a source of fat or
protein like nuts or nut butter would
definitely help her out but for a small
tyover snack especially if you're not
super hungry totally a nutritious choice
let's see what she's having for dinner
see carrots avocado mystery greens and
rice yeah
ow baby is asleep pretend I'm gonna make
a red lentil curry alright so we see the
meal prep hunger hit again with Jen a is
snacking on some tortilla chips and I
think another orange while she's cooking
I mean let's be real we a whole do it
isn't that the benefit of being the one
to do the cooking I mean the chef gets
to eat first but of course I will say if
she's constantly finding herself feeling
famished before dinner can just like get
on the table pairing her earlier orange
with something a little bit more
satiating may help carry her through
obviously no big deal but more of a
suggestion for all of you guys who are
watching who are looking to optimize
your snacks as for her dinner it looks
like we've got a combination of black
and white rice for the carbs lots of red
lentils for some protein and at the end
of the video she also adds some greens
on top and a squeeze of lime juice this
is a super easy balanced meal which
she's made even easier by putting it
into the instant pot I also like that
she adds a squeeze of lime juice because
the vitamin C from the lime will help
the body better absorb the iron from the
lentils now that I'm overly concerned
with Janae's iron intakes because as of
right now they seem to actually be on
point but this is just a general great
nutrition tip especially for individuals
following a plant-based diet or a
menstruating people in general who have
higher needs and baby J's meal also
looks really great I mean we're getting
a little iron from the greens which is
particularly important and well I'm not
really sure what kind of rice babe is
eating if you've got a little one and
you're worried about the arsenic in rice
look for white basmati rice from
California India on Pakistan and sushi
rice from the states
as these do tend to have lower amounts
of inorganic arsenic than brown rice or
rice grown in Arkansas Texas Louisiana
and most other you
States this is actually a huge topic
that I've personally looked into a lot
because my two-year-old adores rice so
if you want a whole video about rice and
arsenic definitely leave me a comment
below all right let's move on to day
three
[Music]
okay so another really busy day for
janae and baby love the idea of oats in
the instant pot to save the day and save
so much time and she adds some pecans
for healthy fats and protein along some
banana for some fruit in addition to the
orange that she has earlier she also has
the matcha latte with some non-dairy
milk which looks amazing
now while this meal is definitely fiber
rich and probably pretty satiating
research does suggest that breastfeeding
people do need extra protein perhaps
even double what their non lactating
counterparts need since so much of that
is going to baby in the milk so to bump
this up we could add some soy milk or
yogurt some hemp parts or some silken
tofu to the oats that would be some
really easy suggestions as for babies
breakfast I love the variety and I also
fully support moms serving their kids
the same thing that they are eating I
mean modeling is so important and I've
heard you talk about this on her channel
but because iron needs are so high
between 6 and 12 months if you wanted to
do regular oatmeal we could up the iron
with some hemp arts nut butter or some
dried apricots in there let's take a
look at snack she is having lentils
brown rice peppers carrots and a little
bit of avocado in there Oh YUM
okay so in this quick clip we see it
janae enjoying an apple while in the
park with baby J well we know the fruit
of course is geneious snack of choice
especially in the mornings I really love
how janae makes sure to add variety by
switching up the types of fruit that
she's eating so for instance she had an
Asian pear and persimmon on day one an
orange on day two and now an apple on
day three so I'm really glad to see that
even though she likes some level of
routine in having her fruit first thing
in the morning as her snack she's still
flexible when it comes to adding variety
and Jays lunch looks amazing
I love that she's got her practising
with her little baby spoon honestly
janae you are going to be so happy that
baby J has mastered that skill early
let's take a look at what she's making
for lunch just some corn and bell pepper
sauteed with garlic some of the link
tool like burrito taco meat with walnut
brown rice that looks amazing
I love the lentil and walnut combination
as kind of a ground meat swap because
not only does it kind of feel like
animal protein it also provides a good
amount of protein fiber and healthy fats
burrito bowls I think are just a really
great adaptable recipe and janae it
totally makes it work with what she has
on hand in quarantine we've got some
carbs from the brown rice and corn
healthy fats from the guac and the
walnuts protein from the lentil meat and
a little veg in there look super
delicious let's see her snack this is
Heilbrun but for my toast I justit's a
tahini which I made it home
and I'm gonna put some sweet potato
butter on it love this nice sweet and
salty combination with Ezekiel bread
homemade tahini and sweet potato butter
this is my kind of snack right here
we've got protein fiber and some carbs
from the bread healthy fats and protein
in the tahini and a little more carbs in
the sweet potato butter plus Ezekiel
bread is made with sprouted grains and
sprouting actually helps to reduce the
number of anti nutrients and may help
improve the absorption of important
vitamins and minerals
let's finish things off by taking a look
at dinner dinner I'm gonna make ten they
take a masala
I'm gonna be using tempeh I myself made
at home last week
[Music]
I just need to say that this vegan tikka
masala looks amazing and even more so
knowing that gen8 made the tempeh
herself girl you are making all the rest
of us moms out there look really bad
just kidding I mean seriously though I
am impressed especially as a new mom in
kovat times come on but we've got some
complex carbs from the butternut squash
and the rice high fiber veg from the
cauliflower and of course protein from
the tempeh and some fat for cooking in
just some all-around really great
balance and for those of you unfamiliar
with tempeh as Jenny mentions it's made
from fermented soybeans which actually
helps to improve digestion by acting as
a prebiotic to feed healthy gut bacteria
not to mention that tempeh is rich in
protein fiber iron and calcium making it
an excellent plant based protein option
I don't see why baby Jake couldn't
totally get in on that it would be a
great nutrient dense compliment to her
cauliflower and squash and very much so
safe to eat at her age so hopefully babe
will get to sample at the family recipe
really soon now in general is this way
of eating a balanced I would say
definitely
I mean Jenny's meals are not only
wonderfully balanced nutritionally but
she also adds a ton of variety to her
meals as well she does a great job of
rotating her plant-based protein sources
between tofu chickpeas black beans
lentils walnuts and tempeh and she adds
different carbs like various fruit rice
sweet potato squash bread and corn now
her macronutrient ranges are
consistently within the recommendation
and she's also exceeding her fiber
calcium and iron intakes for the day I
will say on some days her fiber does get
pretty high almost three times the 25
gram recommendation but judging by her
videos on transitioning to a plant-based
diet I would bet that this probably
doesn't really bother janae since her
gut has grown accustomed to eating a
large amount of fiber rich carbs but I'm
just flagging this because you know
for a lot of average people's guts it
might be a lot to handle so if you're
watching this and you're trying to eat
more plant-based you'll want to add that
fiber and slowly prevent a lot of
bloating and digestive distress now in
terms of calories we had to make some
serious estimations since some of her
meal prep wasn't really shown and it was
hard to know exactly how much of what
was being added but it looked to me
around 2,000 calories a day give or take
and I don't know how much milk
janay is producing and she probably
doesn't know if she's nursing but it is
possible that she could use a little bit
more fuel to optimize her own nutrition
and make enough for babe especially
because it's somebody's harder to get
enough calories when a higher fiber
intake makes you feel so full but on
average breastfeeding people need around
an extra 500 calories above their
baseline but because J's on cells now it
is possible that she's not taking in as
much it's very hard for me to
conclusively say and it doesn't really
matter because from watching janay it's
pretty clear that she is really just
following her hunger cues snacking
whenever she's hungry and grabbing
whatever is convenient and delicious
looking if I was seeing a lot of diet
talk and restriction happening I might
be worried especially when nursing a
baby but I think we have a real
intuitive eater on our hands so it's
just not my concern the only reason I
bring this up is that so other nursing
people out there who are eating like
3,000 calories don't worry that they're
eating too much follow those hunger cues
nourish your body however you can I mean
get somebody else to make sure that
there is always food around for you to
eat because breastfeeding and Parenthood
is hard enough mama you are doing so
great
now what can we take away from Jenny's
channel overall I honestly think there
is a lot that we can take away from
jenay's channel whether you're vegan or
you're just simply trying to incorporate
more plant-based foods into your diet in
a really simple and practical way all of
the recipes I saw here are balanced
nutrient-dense and they're just super
simple with no fuss and as we saw many
of her recipes can meet in the instant
pot it doesn't get easier than that in
addition to providing information on our
channel about how to eat vegan on a
budget as well as easy vegan meal prep
ideas and hacks Jenay also provides some
really helpful and practical information
on how to start eating more plant-based
so for example she talks about the
importance of taking a b12 supplement
introducing foods slowly to allow your
body time to adjust eating more fiber
reading food labels and meal prepping so
amazing she also revives some really
helpful suggestions on how to satisfy
cravings for animal-based foods by
giving tips on kind of mimicking the
flavor and texture of common foods like
graham meat eggs or cheese in addition
to this Jenny also talks about the
importance of having a healthy mindset
when starting a vegan diet by thinking
about it in terms of eating more Whole
Foods rather than depriving yourself of
food this is exactly what I always say
about thinking about adding foods not
taking them away
Jenny also acknowledges that while vegan
foods do tend to be lower in calories it
doesn't mean that you should feel
deprived but rather you should give
yourself permission to eat enough to
feel nourished and satiated this is a
really important message because I know
a lot of people assume that plant-based
diets will inevitably leave you super
hungry fatigued or nutritionally
depleted and while that does happen I
mean it can and does happen with any
diet I think Jenny is a really great
example of how following a vegan diet
can be wholesome nourishing sustainable
and also super easy to pull off when it
comes to talking about wellness topics
like bloating or immunity I also
appreciate that Jenny
generally does so in a very balanced way
without providing a lot of
misinformation so for instance in her
video on how to boost immunity which she
released at the top of the pandemic she
talks about the importance of rest
exercise staying hydrated gut health
managing stress limiting alcohol as well
incorporating a variety of plant-based
foods to increase vitamin C and
antioxidants in takes these are all
evidence-based tips on how to support
general immunity and not once does she
imply that doing these things will
prevent or cure Coppa 19 so thank you to
Jenna for not adding fuel to the fire
when it comes to the misinformation
around Cova and immunity which as you
know I covered at length in my video
right here similarly in her video about
how to reduce bloating she discusses the
importance of eating fiber maintaining
healthy gut bacteria exercising to
promote digestion and keeping a food
journal to keep track of any food
triggers that might be causing digestive
distress keeping a food journal is
particularly important as the vegan diet
tends to be a little bit higher in
fodmap foods which can cause excess gas
and bloating in those who are sensitive
so if you want to learn more about
bloating on a vegan diet and FODMAPs
I cover it in a lot more detail right
here finally are there any problematic
claims or assumptions made by this
channel well one thing I just want to
flag on Janae's channel is her language
around describing bloating so for
instance she talks about controlling
bloat in order to have a flat tummy or
to keep things nice and tight so that
stuff doesn't hang out Jenna even makes
a comment that even if she's not
actually gassy that she doesn't want to
look bloated now dye culture is already
brittle dwith enough messages on the
importance of having a flat tummy and
had a deep bloat with different bogus
supplements and teas and while I do
think janae has really good intentions
with the information that she provides
her followers I do just wish that the
focus could be more on controlling
bloating to reduce physical discomfort
rather than reducing bloating to look a
certain socially acceptable way another
thing that I briefly want to highlight
in flag is that in one video
I caught janae promoting one of the most
ridiculous diets I've ever reviewed food
combining
so she shares that she follows the food
combining rule of eating fruit in the
morning and avoiding fruit too close to
a cooked meal to reduce bloating so now
the solo fruit meals and snacks kind of
make more sense
except they don't anyway Jenny's
rationale is that fruit digests really
quickly and that eating fruit after a
cooked meal prolongs digestion and
causes bloating this is just not
evidence-based folks and I've already
debunked this theory ad nauseam in my
videos here and here
but even though food combining is
totally BS I do appreciate that janae
acknowledges that this is just what
works for her anecdotally even if there
is not much science to back it up so if
eating fruit in the morning and in
between meals
feels good to janae great but I just
wish that this routine didn't need to be
tied to a bogus theory that is just not
evidence-based bottom line Janae's
channel is a great resource for vegan
meal inspiration and cooking hacks and
is an awesome example of how to follow a
vegan diet in a healthy and sustainable
way without deprivation or restriction
she's also super adorable and a pleasure
to watch and I think she's a great role
model for a lot of us busy parents so if
you're not following sweet potato soul
already be sure to head on over to her
channel and be inspired well folks that
is all for today's video if you liked it
be sure to give it that thumbs up leave
me a comment below with who you'd like
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]
you